hello it minecraft i back i
go to kill
[Music]
enderman and collect soul
in stone i do that
yes i have ender soul stone
i went to nether it'd been a while
since i last play and i always forget
what me do
and when me forget what me do me
look dumb ok i started recording and i
didn't even decide what i was going to
do so i need to decide on the fly and
try to make it look like i knew what i
was doing the entire time
almost too easy anyway i'm making a
chest
making chest very important in minecraft
because
uh you got a lot of crap and uh
yeah why do i have cream i can make
bone meal i can make a lot of bone meal
which means that i can make a lot of
plants which means that i can make a lot
of cows
but i don't even need to make cows
anymore that's not the thing
i could milk you
i could milk all of you can i milk you i
i'll let you guys milk each other
can i enchant my axe i'm very efficiency
if it's
e4 that's pretty good hey hey that'll do
nice don't mind me everybody just a guy
with an
axe coming through your village on a
horse
oh you stay there horsey oh my goodness
probably just made a diamond one
probably horribly inefficient
yeah whatever who cares i spent all that
time making the enchanting table i might
as well use it on whatever i feel like
that's what minecraft's all about just
doing whatever you feel like right
right yeah that's probably right okay
horsey
where'd you go where'd you go horsey oh
schwoompi
hey how you doing okay hi ho schwoompi
away yup
yup yeah go over the roofs this seems
logical
don't mind the minor damage to your
house
it's fine and there you are with your
friend so i got wood why did i get wood
i'll tell you why i got wood it's very
obvious
why i got wood i got wood because
don't ask me why i got wood you don't
need to know why i got wood
i got wood and that's the end of it
that's all you need to know
so now what was i gonna do with the wood
i had a plan for the wood
oh i got a plan for the wood i don't
have a plan i have a plan
and that plan is
something oh i got a lava pit well i
might as well just burn this diamond
pickaxe it's pretty much dead right
there's no way to repair something right
someone speak before i do this
there she goes i probably upset someone
i sent a disturbance in the force
i said some people give oh no what have
i done what did i do
did i do something bad ah whatever if i
did i'll own the mistake
or i'll blame someone else like lixian
hey felixian why didn't you stop me from
doing that stupid thing unless it wasn't
a stupid thing and then it's fine
but come on good job
at failing
glad we cleared that up okay all right
he'll never do it again um
hi welcome back to minecraft it's time
to get serious about getting
towards the end of this adventure which
means that we need
to go find more endermans
to be able to stab this isn't where my
this is a different
play the wait no it's the same place but
it's slightly
idiot are there going to be endermen
down there there better be because i'm
going to end
their men for women
and the children too it's a quote i'm
not crazy it's a quote from a movie
if you're quoting things it's okay there
was also an update to this game since
the last time i played i have no idea
what the update includes
and frankly i probably don't care unless
it
affects me negatively and then i care
very much and i ask why
why did you make these changes there's
an ending umu
let me get my stick on before i make a
mistake
ha ha whoa quick you're quick
[Music]
oh there's two oh there's two didn't
realize oh i thought
i thought it was just the one of you oh
my goodness okay this is a problem
okay
okay ow you're not gonna kill me
pearls no pearls why no pearls
why no pearls why you know pearl why
pearl no
why no pearl just give me pearl give
pearl i'm heather yeah i'll come hither
oh
okay all right do not drop in the lava
because then yeah i won't get your pearl
pearl pearl yes
how many do i need i know that you need
to collect them to be able to make
a portal not a nether portal a different
portal to get to the end and when you
get to the end then you can kill the
dragon
i don't necessarily know how to kill the
dragon i'm assuming i hit it with my
sword a lot
but other than that i don't really know
hi
blinkist doing
pearl no no pearl there's a lot of
grumbling
there's got to be a better way there's
got to be a better way right
is there a way to like attract the
attempt maybe
what if i can buy them
the villagers the villagers have
stuff maybe one of them's weird and has
a pearl on them you get what i'm saying
everybody you get what i'm saying
you understand what i'm going for
everybody at home you understand what
i'm talking about
maybe the villagers i almost died
that would have been tragic to lose
literally everything that i have on me
which is
literally all my valuables which would
be literally
earth-shatteringly bad
hey hey hey hey hey hey hey all right
oh it's night okay well that's something
um considering it's night i'm guessing
they're all going to be asleep but
also are there going to be endies
no okay never mind okay good night
this game is being
stubborn people speedrun this in like no
time how am i having trouble with this
i definitely know what i'm doing all
right let's go see what the townspeople
want i
i i spawned by this village way long ago
and i
never really bothered trying to trade
with anybody you
okay you look if they have a hat
they're a thing this person's a farmer
so you got far so i gotta find like the
freak
i gotta find like the weirdo no
are they in the middle of the street
are they are they
what's happening what what just happened
what did i just see
let's see and if it was in any way of
obscenes
blur it i'm leaving this up to you
the fate of my channel rest in your
hands whatever hey hi
anybo hi what are you doing over there
give me some pearls
trying to interact with the farms folk
is
tedious no i can't steal i couldn't it's
wrong
it'd just be wrong it'd be so wrong i
couldn't do that to them
i shan't i shouldn't what is this a
bucket can you guys be anything more
exciting than just farmers
i'm going to the village across the way
they're going to have some good stuff
i know this because i trust them and if
they don't i will burn their entire
village down to the ground i should take
schwumple
to burn their entire village down to the
ground
to burn their entire village down to the
ground
hi hey how you doing
squawk i'm assuming that if i run over
livestock they die
anybody heard of the eye of ender
anybody heard of the ender that's
interesting that's a different building
got p-colored windows wow
never seen a building with pee windows
hello anybody want some beef
hi oh hi how are you doing
cleric rotten fl why do you want rotten
flesh
don't haum me why do you want rotten
flesh
what is that brewing stand
what's a brewing stand this guy
i think he built a better tower than me
my tower is way better oh god it's not
oh ow we're out of here
time to burn this town down to the
ground
hey well hi guys welcome to minecraft uh
been a while since
i've been back uh so i've devised my
plan then i'm gonna do
so i've got some ender pearls
which i know to use i've got some magma
cream
which i know how to use so what i need
to do
is i need to figure out just exactly
what it is that i'm doing with my life
because if i don't figure that out i'm
going to explode
literally in a million pieces i'm gonna
blow up there's gotta be a better way
i also don't necessarily know if that's
the only thing i need and i refuse to
look up anything
you know if a game needs you to look up
a walk-through then it wasn't complete
in the first place and it didn't have
everything that it needed to get in
the way it needed to get in that's my
philosophy and my philosophies are never
wrong
[Music]
hey guys welcome back to minecraft this
is
part 17 in the series and uh given that
i've been playing so long i definitely
know what i'm doing
and today you know i'm venturing forward
to get towards the end of the game here
so uh the first thing i'm going to do is
i'm going to take schwoompi here
and we are just going to go you know
we're going to go this
world is vast it's full of wonder
it's full of things that i have yet to
even
remotely experience and if i don't take
shumple out i'll never be able to find
the destiny that lies beyond the horizon
the eternal
never it's an ocean i found an it's
okay
hey guys welcome back to minecraft this
is partner
of the series and you might be wondering
why i'm not back at my base right now
well it's because i'm out on an epic
adventure with schwoompi here
i just decided that swoopy needed to get
some air and get away from that golem
that was bothering her so much
lixian put in a shot of the golem
bothering schwoompi
yeah oh what a menace anyway so we're
just catching some breeze we're just
catching it you know and if we find
something we find some we're just going
out into the wild open yonder just to
really explore
because i haven't given this game a
chance to see what other things are
around in this game
now i definitely know where i'm going i
definitely know what i'm looking for
and when i find it oh you're gonna see
it i can't wait to show you i'm
basically an expert at this game and if
if i wasn't it'd be really sad and
disappointing if not cause
man i've been playing in a while and you
know she'd think i'd know what i was
doing at this point but yeah i do
i mean i do that's what i was saying i
do know what i'm doing at this point
so why would anybody suspect it's so
funny i'm telling a joke is actually
what it is
crazy if i didn't know but i do and
that's why it's funny the joke that i'm
telling
you can laugh in the comments type a low
low low low
and i'll know what you mean it means
laugh out loud out loud
i am using the patented horse leaf jump
technique
it is very skilled takes a lot of
practice many years
you you'd understand i've been playing
this game for years now but i go you
know i go where the i go where destiny
tells me to go which is
this way uh i consult to destiny and i
know what it is
anyway like i said before destiny
hey guys welcome back to minecraft we're
hit okay
hey guys welcome back to minecraft we're
hitting it again uh with old schwoompi
we're taking swampy out for a ride i
wanted to go out in the night
uh just to let her you know let her
heart
soar it's very important to let your
animal friends hearts
soar uh so i'm just giving shrimp an
opportunity to let her heart
soar uh so when you let your uh your
animal compatriots heart
sore really uh really strengthens the
bond
between the two of yous you know what i
mean everyone knows what i mean you know
what i'm talking about we all know what
i'm talking about
and i'm actually appreciative that you
do know what i'm talking about what is
this is this a village
it is a village they've got a dock is
that a dock
they got a dock you have a doctor
hey guys welcome back to minecraft
decided to take schwampel back into the
woods
the jungle actually sorry my apology
swoopy it's okay don't be upset
uh just decide to get her back to her
roots she was born in the jungle you
know
all horses do originate deep deep in the
jungles
um so i wanted her to get back to her
roots you know
let her soul sing you know you got to
let your animal compatriots souls
sing it's very important it really
strengthens the blonde
hey guys welcome back to minecraft uh
we're just coming back to the base we
had a nice
uh soul session you know bonding moment
with schwumple here but it's time to get
back in here and get down to business
you know it's been a while since i
played this game before so i really
wanted to get down to brass tacks here
[Laughter]
you thought you could mess with a golem
that's weirdly in the pen with uh
schwampel there but uh you could not
oddly enough you could not okay so where
we stand right now
in case you forgot from before where we
stand right now is we've got
six ender pearls now i still don't know
necessarily how many ender pearls that
we need
but as i scan the horizon i
see that there's no other ender
men or women present which is fine
kind of fine so what i'm going to do is
i'm going to do a bold move
it takes bold moves to make what
oh so it was a water zombie it takes
bold moves to make mad moves happen when
you're playing minecraft you gotta do
big plays that's what it's all about
you gotta do the big plays gotta be
willing to do the big plays
and i'm always willing to do the big
plays i'm making
two of these bad boys why i can and i
did it's too late
already done thought i wasn't gonna do
it i did it i'm a man of decisive action
when it comes to
this game
whoa well that's pretty good that's g4
i think it's silk touch silk touch does
a weird thing though
anyway fortune that sounds good that's a
pretty good pickaxe
anyway so i'm gonna use this i'm gonna
maybe i should just look things up you
know maybe i shouldn't just
maybe i shouldn't just wander around
cluelessly and i should
actually look things up so that i can
make some intelligent progress
what is this thing i made this a long
time crossbow
tripwire hook how do you make a drip
wire what
i want to make a crossbow oh forget
everything else that i was talking about
i'm going to make a crossbow
oh my god i made it i love
me i need i hate you
wait i know i know a thing
i know a thing i know a thing i know a
thing or two about a thing or two oh i
know a thing or two
i know a thing or two about a thing or
two let me show you the thing or two
that i know
about a thing or two okay first step
bread
get the bread that's oh you get the bro
get the bread when you get the bread
you're gonna make the bread and i'm
about to make the bread
so now that i got this i'm about to make
that bread and you might be asking
yourself why i'm
hey guys welcome back to minecraft here
at it again with another
epic adventure you know i love this game
it really shows the the heart of the
warrior
um and i got that i have that 100 i'm
not even bragging about i just i have
the heart of the warrior i have the
constitution of the warrior i have the
fortitude of the warrior
i have the heart of the warrior is
really what i have so you know it's been
a while since i played this game so but
we're coming back to it
uh nice and fresh you know we're playing
around with
some different experimentations that we
can do with the game i've come up with
quite a few advanced tactics to this
game
that really are going to aid me in the
long run and that's really what i'm
concerned about the long run and so when
i have the long run
wrapped up locked in i'm gonna know
exactly what the long run is all about
you
hey potatoes
well i'm gonna get to you one second i
gotta sell my
bread to someone who's gonna buy it
wants bread bread
[Music]
[Applause]
no no i just turned all my wheat into
bread
okay carrots
[Applause]
carrot me or i'll carrot you carrot
and another carrot and there
and a boinkish okay enough carrots to
plant back down all right where is that
the arrow man man it's just
instinct that i know where he is hey
take those give me the all right
crossbow was this worth it
welcome back guys to minecraft you may
be wondering where i got this crossbow
it's actually a really high uh tier
weapon
it it's pretty up there like it's really
up there
uh the the capabilities of this weapon
are extremely up there as
as it's called in the business it's
called being up there
and uh this definitely has a lot of the
qualities that
one would uh one would want from
something that is up there
uh and this one is definitely up there
it's almost terrifying just how up and
there
it actually is very tough to manage but
i can do it because i'm a professional
especially at minecraft hey guys welcome
back to minecraft it's my name is
markiplier
uh here back again with another
adventure oh yeah this is exactly what
we're looking for
in the background i got myself a
crossbow using a tripwire hook
some wood some string i traded up my
wheat and carrots
for emeralds and i was able to get some
uh some
arrows from the fletcher and uh you know
it's all good because i'm gonna enchant
this bad boy crossbow right here
bada boom piercing four now that's
that's probably close to the highest
level of piercing that you can get
right all things considered it's a
really good crossbow it's like a really
good crossbow
uh i'm actually going to put away my axe
for now
it's actually top tier strats to put
away the axe
and i'm going to bring the crossbow down
to lo number three
that way i can have it ready for when i
see an enderman
and and i'm rocking i'm rocking a cool
six ender pearls right now
i got one in the meantime that you guys
didn't see uh so i'm not gonna cool
six ender pearls right now uh which
means that i'm gonna be able to get
that ender portal and get to the ender
dragon
and give him a little crossbow action in
the face if you know what i mean
i know you're probably wondering what
the destructive potential of this well
just watch because
it's about to go down i loaded it you
have to load it apparently you prime it
you aim it oh i was aiming for that fish
as you can see
clearly can i get that back can i have
that back did i get it back
i did get it back it's it's a really
cool thing about the crossbows you can
actually
uh get it back
[Music]
bam one shot one kill
that sheep will never see its family
again his family will never see that
sheep again more specifically so with
this new crossbow i'm going to venture
off
into the uh apparently you can melee
i'm going to venture off into the
nether because no matter what i gotta
kill me some
endermen so i go out here and then at
night
i can come back if i know when night is
and oh you got a crossbow i got a
crossbow
it didn't kill you uh this will no this
will this will
easy hey there's one hey stand still
there kirby
you didn't stand still um
oh that was gonna be a face shot stop
moving
you move again i will i swear you oh
you better stop moving oh you better
stop moving
whoa you all right we're going swordies
oh my god you uh do they like pearl okay
good do they like dodge
do they just dodge them is that what
they do is that what they do because
that that'd be dumb
anywho just going to get my bow
arrows back they're called arrows but i
call them
arrows in the business when you're in
the business you call things
colloquially and shorthand because you
gotta
you gotta be fast with the things you
gotta be quick
you know your reaction times gotta be
smooth and when you when you've got
smooth reaction time then you you know
what you're doing alexia make this
good can you make it good can is this
video recoverable is a video good have
you
like which one did you start it on which
which uh beginning did you start it on
i'll just start over again
everybody my name is markiplier welcome
back to minecraft
we're in the nether and we've got a few
advancements that we didn't have before
advancements are when you make
improvements on previously established
technology which i have done
creepy music happening i better watch
out anyway i have a crossbow and i've
enchanted it with piercing
four and i'm on a hunt for endermen now
this one's unsuspecting cross away it's
about to get a face full of bow
bowing now there's an arc to crossbows i
did that intentionally so that you would
know
leave the target now lead
ow can you just not can you not hit them
with this can you not hit them
now when you have the crossbow that
you've spent a lot of effort and time
getting in place
you got to make sure you dry dry again
because eventually you're going to hit
one of these suckers right in the middle
of the eyes
got him oh wait no i forgot about that
whole
deal all right hi
yeah i forgot about that hey
can i have your pearl sorry to ask so
bluntly but i need it for stuff and
things
you give me i have another pearl oh wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait
squeeze
what's with that sword you don't get
enchanted swords i get enchanted swords
okay so it might be night out so i'm
gonna go back out the plan
the plan that i i definitely didn't tell
you about you yet
is i'm gonna go out i was gonna go in
here kill some endermen
go outside it'll be night i'll kill more
endermen
and then i'll get enough pearls to do
with the thing that i need to do
almost too easy i wish you could take
things like these
swords that they drop and break them
down into their components or something
or maybe get experience levels out of
just
you know eating them or something i want
to eat gold is what i'm saying
all right plan executed flawlessly it is
now night and all i need to do
is find
myself some andy poos
i wonder how far away you can look at
them for them to come
get you you know what i'm saying i'm
gonna intelligently
from the top of my tower to make it an
even bigger tower
i'm going to intelligently hey
i'm hey there we go i'm gonna
get this is perfect i call this how do i
get down
wait there's water i will hit that water
i will hit
that water if i hit the water no damage
will be dealt
no damage almost enderman
you i'm looking at you he's coming i'm
looking at you
oh i found the strat i'm looking at you
it's not working
well there's a limit apparently which is
dumb and stupid and also
dumb all right i just got to hit my
target actually i guess if i drop
straight down here i'll go all the way
down right i've got water down there
okay i hit the ladder where'd that
one go where'd he go
oh good way you will oosh
where'd he go there was like so many of
them it was like
you let the other one go you
i'm looking at you come hither
yeah uh-huh uh-huh oh my god that's a
lot of enemies coming
uh oh boy
well that helped unless it blew up the
pearl and then uh he's not dead that's
that's the other thing
oh is that a pearl i think i got a pearl
i think i got one
i think i got one baby all right so
there was some across the way
[Music]
oh oh i'm almost dead actually i just
noticed that
that's probably not good with my
beef with beef please one beef for me
beef beef baby
i forgot they blew up okay good uh i got
one more
so i'm up to three now which would bring
me up to nine
is nine a special number nine it's kind
of a special number in this game
don't blow up don't don't no no no
nine's kind of a special number in this
game right we're good here that was a
productive night
and by that i mean i've gotten one more
this is kind of
difficult to get enough but i've got
ender pearls do i
what do i make with them
[Music]
i can make a cookie what do i
[Music]
hey guys what's up back with minecraft
all right we're all done
thank you everybody so much for watching
i think i'm missing something
i will figure out what it is in the next
episode
thank you and as always i will see you
in the next video don't tell me what it
is that i'm missing don't tell me
i'll figure it out i'll find it oh i'll
find it
[Music]
bye-bye
[Music]
you